NASA could put humans in orbit around
Mars in the year 2033 2033 is not
arbitrary it's when there's a pretty
good orbit there's pretty good orbits
happen often enough but 2033 is a real
good orbit of the Earth and Mars so you
could get humans in orbit around Mars
without raising the NASA budget beyond
letting it increase with inflation which
is an increase but not an extraordinary
one furthermore in order to pull this
off without any increase in the NASA
budget
everybody has to stick to these
agreements that NASA will no longer be
the lead funder or supporter of the
International Space Station in 2024 that
they're gonna retire the space station
or let commercial entities take it over
but if you did that really stuck to the
agreements and you let the NASA budget
increase with inflation you could have
humans orbiting Mars in 2033 if the Mars
2020 Rover is enabled to land in a place
where there might be salty water or
ancient salty water and were to discover
evidence of life perhaps soon it would
accelerate that schedule as we say if
you really had a plan to really put
humans at orbiting Mars in 2033 which
would enable them to land two three or
four years later land on Mars people
would come out of everywhere to
volunteer for that mission we have
astronauts we'd have mission controllers
we'd have engineers we'd have venture
capitalists enabling new technologies to
be sold to NASA or other space agencies
and if you included other space agencies
around the world
raus cosmos the Russian Space Agency
Chinese Space Agency even which is
politically difficult but nevertheless
possible Indian Space Research
Organization Jack said Japanese
aerospace exploration agency if you
included all those guys you could lower
the price for NASA and then really
enable humans to get there in new cool
ways and the reason
go everybody is not to go live on Mars
that's just beyond you just haven't
thought through how difficult that is
when there's nothing to breathe not just
nothing to drink or eat but nothing to
breathe that makes it complicated okay
then but if you were to find evidence of
life it would change the course of human
history not overnight but over the
course of months and years everybody
would get to thinking about what it
means to be a living thing in the cosmos
and they it would it would change us